send someone you used to be into a video
of you slowly rubbing your hands
together over and over slowly slowly
welcome to social sabotage yeah the game
that ruins your perfectly curated
digital life in exchange for money or
whatever it doesn't matter
I'm sorry bad we have two teams gangstas
in Paradise and rich and shameless all
right the yellow cars will be where you
post the black cars will be what you'll
post so like a picture video something
weird first seem to follow through gets
one point first to five wins the grand
prize of $500 you ready yep alright
let's play social sabotage yeah all
right send a sibling my breath smells
like beef jerky
what's sibling what's sibling is it
gonna be
wait smells like bitter they're both
wrong set it again set it again my
breath smells like beef jerky my breath
smells like ah yes boys tanks it's still
sending it's not saying it's actually
just sent it you guys Oh 312 311 rich
and shameless gets one point not only
that text my brother but that was a
group chain to my dad as well Wow so
double yeah do I get anything no no you
don't get anything better I thought I'd
send your tenth most recent text 10th
most recent so soon some math and bolts
real love is never having to say I love
you
[Music]
never happened
deliver Wow Wow all right another boy
did not happen that one's gonna come
with a phone call
Oh was it who did you set who's the
tenth most reason he texted me in my
defense
good morning but it was a football
player a new way back in the day Wow
most recent text is someone trying to
send someone you've slept with oh it's
go time
I think my rash is spreading should I
keep using the cream wears it and I like
what is it let me see let me see
3:53 gangsters and posters how's your
rash it's going great yeah three texts
so far he's all too rash one after
another yeah look I think I saw an lol
pop-up so so now it's probably a good
time to mention the prize money will be
distributed based on how many points
each player on the winning team won for
posting so if you posted three things
you get $300 if you post two you get
$200 you post nothing you don't get
anything all right let's do it all right
send a new friend who you haven't gotten
to know very well yet do you mind if I
use pictures of you on my tinder profile
one person Christina bison 14 you want
to do it whenever losed up oh my god
censored all right that's one boy boys
Ritchie shameless all right next one
send the last person you kiss a photo of
the face you'd make if you walked in on
your parents doing it post an Instagram
story with a video of you speaking in a
baby voice is any weird
Wow yes let's look at the time just two
seconds wait it's a gangster's in
paradise
all right so next card send someone
you've only met once a photo of a vague
body crack so he can be your hand right
oh I just went straight to ask come on
come on she doesn't even have the number
she's sending it to her post mate sunday
sunday
in doing it I'm already too behind as
another boy for written in a couple
hours don't worry buddy
[Music]
send someone you used to be into a video
of you slowly rubbing your hands
together over and over aka at least
three seconds long three seconds long of
you doing Birdman head slowly slowly
just yeah yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
whatever is that girl you just text me
[Laughter]
Patrick gets $200 Krystal gets $300 UI
of that rascal
still itchy okay everybody you're off
the hook so you guys can explain what
you've been doing that you've been
playing a game called social sabotage
make a couple calls see your loved ones
all right thanks for playing good night
yeah baby that was in a real rash
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
you